i got pregnant shooting this film
hollywood movie magic
never fails to impress especially when
it comes to the way they hide baby bumps
hollywood has come up with all kinds of
tricks to cover up the bumps
which superhero's baby bump had a cape
of its own who was it that lied to get
out of wearing a corset while pregnant
we've got all the hollywood secrets
really you don't think that's a little
inappropriate what hathaway managed to
keep her pregnancy a secret since she
was only in her first trimester for much
of the filming
when she started her second trimester
she shared it with a few people
but since her costumes were still
fitting her well she was able to get
away with not telling everyone
a reason and i couldn't say because i'm
five weeks pregnant
she was nearly caught when the costume
designer wanted to put her in a corset
but
she made the excuse that she didn't want
to feel restricted while tap dancing to
get out of it
by the end of filming she was 16 weeks
pregnant and the costume designer
managed
to figure it out wonder woman had a far
from wonderful time on set while filming
pregnant
i can stand and lay down so when i'm
standing i'm with a baby and i'm
you know you just work around it gal
gadot found herself very sick
often vomiting in corners and
consistently dealing with intense
migraines
migraines i vomit whatever i was late to
sad
being five months pregnant didn't stop
her from doing reshoots for the movie
her baby bump got a cape of its own when
shooting in the armor a green cloth that
could be cgi'd in editing
me and maya we came to work together
mandy moore's pregnancy
unfortunately didn't line up with any of
the scenes in which she had to be
pregnant in
so they resorted to prosthetics when she
was actually pregnant
laundry baskets unfitted clothing and
large bags came to the rescue to cover
her bum
when felicity jones became pregnant she
wasn't sure if she'd still be part of
the midnight sky
but the director george clooney wanted
her to be in the film so he wrote her
pregnancy into the script
what are we gonna name her
stunt sequences were altered to make
sure that she could actually do them
safely
jones said that being pregnant while
filming was actually a blessing as it
strengthened her relationship with her
character
sully you're calling me going hey i'm
pregnant i'm like
oh that's that's so great
similarly to felicity jones the initial
plan was to hide the pregnancy
until the decision was made to write it
into the show
morgan didn't have the easiest times
with her pregnancy on riverdale because
it made her
exhausted but she still managed to dance
on stage with snakes
scarlett johansson had a team of stunt
doubles on her side to help when the
actress wasn't able to shoot a
particular scene
camera angles close-ups and costumes
were all contributors to hiding the
superheroes bump as well
johansen spoke afterwards about how
lucky she felt to have such a supportive
cast and crew around her
always checking in and making sure she
was comfortable on set
that has been very liberating just to
kind of make that discovery
courtney cox's real-life pregnancy was a
pretty surprising gift
after suffering multiple miscarriages
over many years the chances of her
having a baby weren't too high
it was even written into the script that
monica and chandler wouldn't have kids
so when she did end up becoming pregnant
the show didn't end up adding a plot
twist for her character
by the end of the series her bump was
pretty obvious since she was four months
pregnant and the production actually
didn't do anything to cover it up
you know taking us through the journey
of their pregnancy shay mitchell was
sneaky with her pregnancy
and actually kept it a secret from the
production since her character's
wardrobe was naturally flowy and baggy
she wasn't too worried about her bump
showing
what gave her pregnancy away was that
she wasn't drinking coffee on set
a staple for any film person that could
be the baby brain but
yeah no it's all really amazing i'm so
excited for people to see this show
sarah power also hit her pregnancy from
the whole cast and crew
which wasn't too difficult since it's
hard to notice watching the series now
that she was with child
fans only discovered her pregnancy when
she posted a photo online on mother's
day
it's hard to let go winslet didn't hold
back when she was pregnant on set for
divergent
the actress really wanted to do a lot of
her own stunts and managed to do some of
the smaller and safer ones on her own
in terms of covering the baby bump an
ipad or large folder being held in front
of her stomach was the simple solution
to hiding her pregnancy
so we actually had to keep adapting the
costumes as we went
evangeline lily's baby bump made fitting
into her wasp suit
very tricky since she'd grown so much it
actually didn't fit her at all
as she's a very private person her
pregnancy only became known at the
premiere of the film when she was seven
months pregnant from pre-pregnancy to
was night and day the sweeney todd
production team came up with a plan
and decided to shoot the film out of
sequence to help with hiding bottom
carter's pregnancy
when her bump was starting to show a
corset and dark costumes helped to cover
things up
unfortunately she didn't have the best
experience and was
super nauseous on set for most of the
filming process
even though she was playing the baker's
wife and could get away with appearing a
bit bigger on screen
being seven months pregnant by the end
of things made it a bit trickier
by the end adjustments were being made
to her costumes every single week and
the film resorted to having james corden
who played her husband
standing in front of her in attempts to
hide the bump
that's that's kind of a good tactic i
think from season two episode nine
onwards of the handmaid's tale ivon
strzhovsky was on set with a baby on the
way
while she experienced a lot of nausea as
many pregnant women do
she also suffered a very odd symptom
excess
saliva so much so that she wound up
carrying around a spittoon onset
she actually managed to hide it from the
cast and crew pretty well who thought
she was just sick with
really odd symptoms we kind of have a
secret
um hope our hope and dream the
production prioritized filming many of
cruz's scenes while she wasn't showing
her bump too much
naturally she couldn't manage all the
stunts herself as they just weren't safe
for her
so her stunt double and sister monica
cruz stepped in for the stunts blake
lively wore a bikini for the majority of
the film the shallows
so it was pretty surprising that we
couldn't tell she was pregnant
even though the film is pretty stunt
heavy a double was never hired
instead some stunts were toned down so
they were safe enough for lively to
perform
i i'm one of five kids my husband's one
of four so
jolie actually didn't know she was
pregnant with twins while she was
filming the changeling
only finding out near the end of filming
she believes the emotions she had from
being pregnant
even unknowingly intensified her
performance in the movie
the tv show scandal didn't go too
high-tech when it came to hiding kerry
washington's pregnancy
furniture and camera angles were the
main tools used to cover it up
behind the scenes washington didn't have
the easiest time since she was
undergoing so many emotional and
physical changes
however her cast and crew were all
really supportive and took great care of
her on set
and i think yeah for me definitely
these two pregnancies have been really
different lane's experience filming
utopia taught her a new skill
how to switch between being at work and
being an expecting mother
while it was a challenge it was one that
she was grateful to learn when it came
to her stunts
her double was the solution being on a
long-running series like grey's
definitely makes hiding pregnancies
trickier oh i have a consult but
i have a consult during season six of
the show cribs and camera angles did the
trick to cover the bun
when it came time for her maternity
leave a storyline involving her donating
part of her liver was written in so she
could take the time off she needed to
care for her newborn
the grey's team is pretty versed when it
comes to working around pregnancies
since there have actually been 25
babies born within the cast over the
duration of the whole series
and i said i don't know if the fans can
handle that
it's pretty amazing to see all the
creative ways pregnancies are hidden and
how supportive the teams are
who knew furniture would be so commonly
used with all of the advanced
technologies available